70 pages c'est pas possible tu rends
compte aristote 70 pages 70 pages c'est
la taille de l'introduction du cours de
culture générale sur le thème des
concours d'un élève de prépa hec qui m'a
écrit on et vous bien compte 70 pages
c'est uniquement pour l'introduction du
coup le cours complet ça va être combien
de pages 500-600 non mais ça va
six cents pages il faut combien de temps
pour les apprendre 600 ans
oui mais d'ici là on sera à télécharger
informations directement dans le cerveau
et si je vous disais que vous pouvez
vous en sortir bien mieux qu'avec le
cours de votre prof
avec seulement dix pages qu'est ce que
c'est la méthode des paragraphes
c'est très simple il s'agit de créer un
stock de paragraphe que vous pourrez
facilement utiliser et réutilisées dans
toutes vos dissertation sur le thème de
l'année
c'est quoi les avantages de cette
méthode vous n'avez plus besoin
d'apprendre le court
vous n'avez plus besoin de trouver des
arguments ni des références et enfin
vous n'avez plus besoin de rédiger le
développement de vos dissertation
puisqu'il vous suffit de recopier les
paragraphes que vous avez préparé
résultats l'épreuve de dissertation est
bien plus facile
vous êtes moins stressés grâce à vos
paragraphe vos arguments vos références
et votre style sont bien meilleurs donc
vos notes d'école et je n'invente pas
parce que depuis que j'ai créé
populariser cette méthode avec manuel 50
paragraphe tout cuit c'était en 2016 et
bien deux puis 2016
j'ai reçu des centaines de témoignages
d'élèves de près page c'est qu'ils m'ont
dit qu'ils avaient gagné beaucoup de
points et beaucoup de temps grâce à ma
méthode des paragraphes
j'ai reçu tellement de témoignages que
cette année il m'a fallu une journée
entière pour les three en fait je dois
être honnête avec vous je ne pensais pas
que cette méthode marcherait aussi bien
la vérité c'est que quand des élèves me
disent qu'ils décrochent dit
suite à la dissertation de culture
générale du concours de hec en ayant
travaillé le thème avec ma méthode
pendant seulement une semaine de toute
l'année la vérité c'est que quand ils me
disent ça je suis un peu gêné mais bon
quand j'apprends que des profs font des
introductions de 70 pages sur le thème
la gêne disparaît bref la méthode des
paragraphes
ça marche très bien et je vais vous
expliquer dans le détail comment moi je
m'en sers dans cette vidéo
si vous voulez voir à quoi ressemble un
stock de paragraphe je vous laisse
regarder mes cinquante paragraphe tout
cuit sur le thème du désir
j'ai rédigé en 2019 vous pouvez accéder
à mon fichier google docs ce soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui s'affiche
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit en cliquant sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo je désire
un coup d'oeil maintenant si vous voulez
mais revenez bien à cette vidéo et
regardez là jusqu'où ecoutez-moi
attentivement jusqu'au bout et dont dix
minutes vous serez exactement comment
gagner facilement des points en
dissertation de culture générale cette
année tout en gagnant beaucoup de temps
la première étape pau créer votre stock
de paragraphe c de subdiviser le thème
de l'année en soute m c'est important
parce que ça va vous donner un meilleur
aperçu du champ intellectuel que vous
devez couvrir et puis surtout parce que
cela va vous faciliter la recherche des
idées des paragraphes
en effet c'est plus facile de chercher
dans un sous thème plutôt que dans un
thème
c'est comme lorsque vous faites un plan
détaillé vous cherchez les idées plus
générale avant les idées plus précises
c'est à dire les grandes parties du plan
avant les arguments
c'est comme si vous deviez chercher un
objet dans un sac à dos plutôt que dans
une valise l'objet sera plus facile à
trouver dans le sac à dos parce que
c'est un espace plus petit mais comment
faire en pratique je vous conseille de
subdiviser le thème en 5 à 8 sous thèmes
4 je pense que c'est trop peu et 9 ça
commence à faire trop donc essayez de
rester entre 5 et 8
par exemple sur le thème de la mémoire
qui était le thème de 2019
j'avais distinguer cette sous thèmes sur
le thème du désir qui était le thème de
2020 jallet distinguer 6 août m
mais comment faire pour les trouver les
sous thèmes si vous ne voulez pas vous
prendre la tête
inspirez vous des chapitres d'un manuel
vous pouvez aussi demander à votre prof
moi personnellement je préfère partir du
concept du thème et on déduire
logiquement les différentes dimensions
avec le thème du désir par exemple
j'avais pensé à la naissance du désir
puis à la logique c'est à dire à la
manière dont fonctionne le désire mais
elle a aussi pensé aux pouvoirs
d'aliénation du désir qui correspond un
peu aux conséquences du désir et enfin
j'avais aussi pensé à la solution ou
pouvoir d'aliénation du désir c'est la
maîtrise du désir bref c'était pour vous
donner un exemple ma manière de trouver
les sous thèmes est plus difficile mais
elles structurent le thème de façon plus
rigoureuse en tout cas ne cherchez pas
la perfection il y aura probablement des
sous thèmes qui se recoupent ont des
idées que vous aurez du mal à classer
mais ce n'est pas grave l'essentiel
c'est que vosu thème vous donne une
bonne perspective sur le champ
intellectuel du thème et qu'ils vous
permettent de trouver puis de classer
les i
les plus courantes dont vous pourrez
vous servir dans vos dissertation allez
on passe à la deuxième étape la deuxième
étape de ma méthode des paragraphes
c'est de trouver les idées les plus
courantes sur le thème dont vous pourrez
vous servir dans vos dissertation en
clair vous imaginez al avance les
arguments avec lesquels vous me bleux
revo plan détaillé cette année comment
trouver ses arguments en pratique vous
devez faire attention à trois choses la
première c'est que vous cherchez des
idées suffisamment général mais pas trop
dans votre contexte les arguments sont
des idées générales de quatrième niveau
je vous donne un exemple sur le thème de
la mémoire la mémoire est un phénomène
collectif est une idée probablement trop
générales pour servir d'argument en
effet la mémoire collective était déjà
un mais sous thèmes sur le thème de la
mémoire et on peut éventuellement
consacré une grande partie de
dissertation à l'idée que la mémoire est
un phénomène collectif donc cette idée
est trop général pour servir d'argument
en revanche la mémoire collective
française est nourri par l'histoire
nationale est une affirmation trop
précises qui servait donc plutôt
d'exemple au sein d'un paragraphe
c'est le fait de parler de la france une
nation particulière qui rend l'idée trop
précises je viens de vous donner une
idée trop générales servir d'argument
puise une des trop précises
donc maintenant je vais vous donner une
idée ni trop générale dit trop précises
une idée adéquate la mémoire collective
pourrait fonder un devoir est une idée
adéquat pour servir d'argument parce que
la précision de la notion de devoir me
permet d'utiliser l'idée pour défendre
une autre idée encore plus générale
celle d'une grande partie de
dissertation voilà pour l'exemple
souvenez-vous donc bien que vous
cherchez des idées générales que vous
pourrez intégrer dans les grande partie
de vos dissertation la deuxième chose à
laquelle vous devez faire attention pour
trouver les arguments de vaud paragraphe
c'est la rentabilité
oui
eh bien oui ça ne sert à rien de vous
prendre la tête à créer un par ailleurs
tout cuisse il vous sert une seule fois
dans l'année
l'objectif c'est au contraire que vos
paragraphe vous servent dans un maximum
de dissertation d'accord mais comment
faire pour estimer la rentabilité des
idées que vous trouvez regardez
simplement leur fréquence dans vos
sources
par exemple si l'idée revient tout le
temps dans le cours de votre prof c'est
probablement qu'elle vous sera utile
pour traiter pas mal de sujets si vous
lisez plusieurs fois la même idée dans
un manuel
c'est pareil elle vous sera certainement
utile
en revanche si vous entendez une idée
une seule fois au cours de l'année et
qu'elle vous paraît original là
attention c'est mauvais signe
alors bien sûr cette façon d'estimer la
rentabilité des idées sur le thème ce
n'est pas un test en laboratoire
c'est au doigt mouillé mais ça marche
puis ça vous permet d'exercer votre
jugement en vous familiarisant avec les
idées les plus courantes sur le thème la
troisième et dernière chose à laquelle
vous devez faire attention pour trouver
les arguments de vaud paragraphe c
l'exhaustivité il faut que vous ayez des
munitions intellectuels pour traiter
tous les sujets mais comment faire là
encore c'est pas une science exacte mais
ça fonctionne je vous recommande trois
choses tout d'abord essayé d'estimer les
poids respectifs des sous-thèmes dans le
thème vous devez vous rendre compte que
les idées de tels sous thèmes vous
seront probablement plus utile que les
idées de tel autre et donc vous savez
que vous avez plus d'idées à trouver
dans certains ce thème là encore vous
vous servirez du cours de votre prof ou
de vos manuels pour estimer les poids
respectifs des sous-thèmes dans le thème
la deuxième chose que je vous recommande
c'est de bien faire attention à ce que
les arguments de haut par ailleurs ce ne
soit pas des idées trop proche si vous
avez deux paragraphes pour défendre la
même idée vous n'êtes pas efficients
vous devez avoir un seul paragraphe pour
défendre chaque idée courante et vous
utiliserez toujours le même
là il sera vraiment rentable enfin la
troisième chose que je vous recommande
que vous soyez sûr de pouvoir traiter
tous les sujets et bien c'est justement
de tri
des sujets prenez une dizaine de sujets
de dissertation bien différent sur le
thème et réfléchissez aux idées vous
pourriez utiliser dans vos plans
détaillés si vous arrivez à remplir vos
plans détaillés c'est que vous avez
probablement assez d'arguments pour
traiter la plupart des sujets mais si
vous avez des trous à combler dans vos
plans détaillés c'est alors qu'il vous
faut davantage d'arguments
là c'est le moment de répondre à une
question importante de combien
d'arguments et donc deux paragraphes
avez vous besoin pour être en mesure de
traiter la plupart des sujets vous serez
très à l'aise avec 50 paragraphe
c'est pour ça que moi j'en écris 50 mes
élèves chaque année mais vous pouvez
très bien vous en sortir avec une
trentaine de paragraphe
et puis si vous n'avez pas beaucoup de
temps eh bien vous pourrez vous en
sortir avec 20 paragraphe à la condition
que leurs arguments soient très rentable
bah oui forcément si vous avez moins de
balles vous avez vraiment intérêt à ce
que chaque balle touche la cible
ouf c'est bon pour la deuxième étape je
suis trop fatigué pour la résumer donc
utiliser le minutage détaillé qui est
dans la description si vous voulez
revenir à un point particulier de cette
étape
allez on passe à la suivante la
troisième étape de ma méthode des
paragraphes c'est de trouver les
références on le savait on dissertation
une référence r a apporté du crédit à
l'argument du paragraphe
donc il est crucial qu'elles soient
pertinentes vous défendez une certaine
idée dans votre paragraphe donc vous
mobiliser une référence pour convaincre
le correcteur que l'idée du paragraphe
est juste
attention donc à ce que la référence
soit bien pertinente par rapport à
l'idée du paragraphe maintenant ou
est-ce que vous trouverez vos références
et bien dans le cours de votre prof dans
des manuels des articles ou
éventuellement dans les vidéos
là c'est le bon moment pour répondre à
une question fréquente vous me demandez
souvent quelle est la bonne proportion
de références classiques ces deux
références originales
je vous conseille une proportion de
pareto grosso modo 80% de référence
classique donc 20% de référence
d'original et puis essayer aussi de
trouver un équilibre entre les
références philosophiques et les
références littéraires
voilà c'est tout ce que j'avais à vous
dire concernant la recherche des
références on passe à la quatrième étape
la quatrième étape de ma méthode des
paragraphes c'est la rédaction des
paragraphes
alors oui je sais c'est chiant et puis
ça prend du temps mais ça va vous
prendre beaucoup moins de temps que
d'essayer d'apprendre et de comprendre
un cours interminables et puis ça a un
avantage c'est qu'en écrivant vos
paragraphe vous allez améliorer votre
style maintenant comment faire en
pratique
bon là je vais pas vous donner les
consignes pendant dix heures je vous dis
simplement fait comme moi je vous laisse
regarder mes cinquante paragraphe tout
cuit sur le désir que j'ai rédigée en
2019 et je vous conseille de faire
exactement comme moi vous pouvez accéder
à mon fichier google docs ce soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui s'affiche
maintenant en haut à droite soit en
cliquant sur celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo concernant la
rédaction d'un paragraphe en lui-même je
vous conseille d'écrire entre 150 et 200
mots parce que c'est la taille moyenne
des paragraphes de dissertation dans les
bonnes copies de vos concours puis si
vous voulez savoir comment écrire un bon
par aillleurs de dissertation et bien
j'ai publié deux vidéos dans lesquelles
je vous explique comment faire dans le
détail dans l'une je vous dévoile les
cinq étapes pour rédiger un paragraphe
de dissertation et dans l'autre je vous
révèle ma formule en six points pour
rédiger un super arguments de
dissertation voilà avec ça vous avez
tout ce qu'il vous faut pour rédiger vos
paragraphe une fois que vous les aurez
rédigé qu'est-ce qui vous restera à
faire
la cinquième étape de la méthode des
paragraphes c'est l'apprentissage des
paragraphes
c'était difficile à trouver évidemment
vous devez à pont-de-vaux paragraphe au
fur et à mesure que vous enrichissez
votre stock mais comment le faire
efficacement en particulier comment
faire pour que ça soit le moins pénible
possible g3 conseil à vous donner
tout d'abord n'apprenez pas par coeur
oui vous avez bien un intérêt à
connaître vos paragraphe par coeur mais
ce n'est pas parce que vous les
connaissez par coeur que vous les avez
appris par coeur
le problème avec l'apprentissage par
coeur c'est que c'est super pénible et
donc ça vous demande une grosse dose de
motivation ça puise beaucoup dans votre
réserve de volonté à chaque fois que
vous devez vous y mettre
et puis il y à un second problème
l'apprentissage par coeur réduit la
capacité à mobiliser le savoir c'est à
dire que vous serez moins bon pour vous
servir de vos parts hagard dans vos
dissertation pour ces deux raisons je
vous conseille donc de vous contenter de
lire attentivement sur vos par ailleurs
alors après c'est quoi mon deuxième
conseil
je vous conseille de créer un rituel
pourquoi créer un rituel est bien parce
qu'à l'inversé de l'apprentissage par
coeur
un rituel économise votre volonté le
principe d'un rituel c'est d'agir sans
prendre de décision
par exemple quand vous devez vous laver
les dents après un repas vous n'hésitez
pas vous ne réfléchissez pas vous le
faites de manière automatique
eh bien vous avez intérêt à faire la
même chose pour apprendre vos paragraphe
lisez les chaque matin lors du
petit-déjeuner ou bien chaque soir avant
de vous coucher
le tout aidé à couper votre rituel
chaque jour est exactement de la même
manière il ne me reste plus qu'un
conseil à vous donner
mettez à profit les circonstances
improductive qu'est ce que ça veut dire
les circonstances d'un productive il ya
des circonstances dans lesquelles il est
difficile de travailler
elles ne sont pas faites pour ça c'est
pour ça que je les qualifie d'
improductif par exemple vous perdez
peut-être du temps dans le métro en
attendant le bus dans la file d'attenté
à la cantine à la bibliothèque ou encore
en attendant l'arrivée du prof
et bien vous pouvez mettre à profit
toutes les minutes perdues de votre
journée pour relire un deux trois
paragraphes et comme ça vous les
connaîtrez encore mieux si vous avez
l'application google docs sur votre
téléphone vous pouvez relire vos
paragraphe partout et vous pouvez même
les modifier et donc les améliorer
lorsque vous les réviser c'est pas
pratique ça
en résumé si vous voulez gagner
facilement des points en dissertation
culture générale tout en gagnant du
temps et bien alors vous avez intérêt à
adopter ma méthode des paragraphes et
pour ce faire vous devez suivre cinq
étapes subdiviser le thème en
sous-thèmes trouver les arguments
trouver les références rédiger les
paragraphes et enfin les apprendre
alors j'ai bien conscience que certaines
de ces opérations sont difficiles pour
un élève peut-être que vous allez galéré
à trouver les idées les plus courantes
sur le thème à dénicher des références
pertinentes
on peut être que vous avez vraiment du
mal à rédiger un paragraphe
c'est pour cette raison que je permet à
une minorité d'élèves de près page c'est
d'accéder à mes 50 par ailleurs tout
cuit sur le thème de l'année
donc là c'est moi qui fais toutes les
étapes pour vous de a à z sauf sauf bien
sûr l'apprentissage je n'ai pas encore
trouvé de solution pour télécharger le
paragraphe dans votre cerveau si mes
cinquante paragraphe tout cuit vous
intéresse vous pouvez en savoir plus
soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche maintenant en haut à droite
soit en cliquant sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo et je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez aussi vous
faire une idée de ce à quoi il ressemble
en regardant ce que j'ai rédigée sur le
thème du désir en 2019
le lien est également dans la
description de cette vidéo
voilà voilà comme d'habitude j'espère
que cette vidéo vous sera utile je suis
romain je suis toujours avec mon fidèle
aristote et vous étiez sûr mais l'idée
de culture générale rappelez vous que
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête pour réussir vos dissertation de
culture générale aux concours des écoles
de commerce
[Musique]